you're like the tofu of people you just
take whatever flavor is around you I'm
like tofu
hello Rooney welcome to Fandango
frontrunner I'm very happy to see you
here your film Carol is so fascinating
not only does it take place in the 1950s
but it feels like an older classic film
was that exciting for you to be a part
of that's one of my favorite things
about the film is that when you watch it
it really does feel like it could have
been made in the early 1950s it doesn't
feel like a film that was made you know
in 2013 about a different era but it
really feels like everything about it
could have been it could have just been
made then and I think it's really
authentic in that way your character
Trez is so fascinating you get the sense
that she's soaking everything up around
her like a sponge what was it about her
that was appealing to you well it was
very different than anything I had done
before and um you know I was excited to
sort of show that side of myself I mean
I can I can heavily relate to that
sponge quality and myself and and then
obviously you know working with Kate and
getting to work with Todd that would
have been reason enough for me to want
to do it and then tell us wrote a really
beautiful adaptation of this really
extraordinary book and so it was there
was kind of it was a very easy yes do
you consider yourself an observer yeah
that that's the that's the way you like
to live your life and whenever you can
you know I don't like to be in crowds I
really feel it I really kind of soak up
everyone else's emotions and moods I
really pick up on that but um yeah I
just I just related to that that part of
trip so I want to take a look at a
really terrific scene of you and Cate
Blanchett in Carol this scene is early
in the film where your character Torres
and Kate's character Carol are really
kind of alone for the first time and
talking for the first time in this
restaurant and it just says so much
without even saying that much so let's
take a look and talk about it so what
kind of name is Bela vet
to check it's changed originally it's
very original well into first name
Torres Torres not Theresa no Torres Bela
vet it's not like and yours
Carol Carol there's so much going on in
your eyes you're darting you're looking
intently you're looking longingly when
you and Todd Haynes the director were
figuring this scene out and talking
about it what was important to you to
get across with your facial expressions
here this was one of my favorite scenes
to shoot and it was one of the first
times that me and Kate actually got to
do a scene together that had any real
sort of meat on it or substance and
there's so much subtext going on in this
scene and you know we had spent so much
time shooting separately or shooting
just little tiny things so to be able to
finally you know play tennis so to speak
with one another was so exciting and
especially because it's Kate it was just
exhilarating the entire the entire day
and we would do these long takes and it
was really um one of my favorite scenes
to shoot ever and the pauses between the
two of you answering each other's
questions and asking questions are just
so fascinating it's it really is like a
sports game all right let's keep
watching so I'm sure you thought it was
a man who sent you back your gloves I
did thought it might have been a man in
this ski Department I'm sorry
no I'm delighted and I'm very much about
had gone to lunch with him hmm I mean
the flirtation is just outrageous
do you have real-life experiences you
can draw from have you ever been this
smitten with somebody yeah I'm sure I
don't know that I've ever I mean I
haven't been in a situation similar to
that but I'm sure I mean I think that's
one of the reasons that the film
resonates with a lot of people is that
Todd really captured the experience of
falling in love and what that feels like
and you know the obsession that you go
through and so definitely you know I in
many ways these characters are taking a
big risk in this time to run away
together to be in a relationship if in
some ways being an actor is a risk
for you is there someone in your life
that really helped you take that leap
someone who encouraged you to follow
this dream you know I mean my sister is
an actress and she started acting
professionally when she was 12 years old
and so she's definitely been been an
encouragement over the years but I mean
I really think I've kind of always been
like a very independent sort of lone
wolf type person and I've always been
kind of secretive even with you know
family members and people close to me
and so I kind of like jumped into it
it's not like I was really focal like
okay I want to do this now and so I
don't know that I really allowed for
people to help me but certainly once I'd
made the decision that I wanted to do it
my sister was very supportive and
helpful so does the inspiration come
from within I don't know I mean I'm just
sort of inspired by storytelling and
also the world you know what the reason
I didn't want to start acting when I was
younger is because I just knew that I
wasn't ready to do that I knew I wasn't
really strong enough to handle sort of
you know it's tough to do it's it's
tough to be an actor at any age but
especially when you're young I mean
adolescence is hard enough without like
being in sort of an adult world and
constant rejection and and all that and
I knew that I wouldn't be able to handle
it and and also I had wanted to sort of
experience life first for me if I work
too much I have to then take a big chunk
of time off to sort of throw myself back
up with life experience and yeah if I'm
not able to do that and I just don't
really feel inspired to act and how
would you say this whole experience has
changed you how are you a different
person after making Carroll I feel like
every every job that I take I change in
some way and learn and learn something
new and hopefully that continues to
happen
for the rest of my career well it's a
gorgeous film so thank you for taking
the time to share your experience about
it I appreciate it
Carol is in theaters so be sure to see
it buy your tickets on Fandango thanks
so much for the TCL Chinese Theatre IMAX
for having us today and thank you for
watching
Fandango frontrunners
[Music]
you